[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas durante la semana
relacionadas con la pandemia de kobe 19
a continuación les presento algunos de
los temas que vamos a tratar en este
programa el 60% de la población indígena
de la isla de pascua es decir unas
10.000 personas fueron convocados para
una consulta no vinculante para
determinar si la isla es abierta
nuevamente al turismo el 67 por ciento
de los que participaron en esta consulta
votó por el no después de casi dos años
cerrada al mundo esta remota isla
chilena seguirá aislada del mundo para
evitar contagios de kobe 19 conversamos
con su alcalde el señor pedro pablo
edmunds para conocer detalles de cómo se
mantiene a flote la economía local que
es dependiente precisamente del turismo
analizaremos también la situación en
perú un países donde se ha demorado la
vacunación en las comunidades indígenas
y también han aumentado los casos de
contagio entre los menores de edad
también hablaremos de la tercera dosis
que va a comenzar a ser suministrada por
parte de las autoridades y también
hablaremos de chile en donde los centros
de vacunación presentan congestión es en
este país también aumentan los casos de
contagio levemente y vamos a ver en
detalle la situación de nicaragua allí
vamos a ver cuáles son las cifras de
contagio de fallecidos y de personas
vacunadas pero haremos énfasis en las
historias de cientos de nicaragüenses
que han tenido que cruzar la frontera
con territorio hondureño para poder
recibir alguna vacuna contra el jove y
19 en minutos les contamos la historia
comenzamos entonces y lo vamos a hacer
con las cifras vamos a ver cómo está el
panorama de el avance de la pandemia de
kobe 19 en diferentes países de nuestro
continente vamos a comenzar en mexico
este país finaliza esta semana con más
de 37 millones de casos confirmados y
más de 287.000 personas han fallecido
allí en costa rica reportan más de 559
mil casos y más de 7 mil fallecidos el
ecuador termina esta semana
contabilizando más de 515 mil casos y
más de 32.000 personas han fallecido en
uruguay en donde reportan ya 392 mil
casos finalizan esta semana con un poco
más de seis mil fallecidos y no muy
lejos de allí en el gigante suramericano
brasil allí contabilizan más de 21 7
millones de casos confirmados a lo largo
de toda la emergencia sanitaria y más de
600 7000 personas
según la ope el continente americano
está en uno de sus mejores momentos o en
el mejor momento en lo corrido del año
referente a la situación de la pandemia
de kobe 19 y por eso han podido relajar
algunas de las medidas sanitarias para
las fiestas de fin de año que ya están
prácticamente a la vuelta de la esquina
vamos a conversar con el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo también
asesor científico de france 24 ya está
con nosotros para nuestra habitual
consulta doctor bienvenido como siempre
un gusto tenerlo con nosotros y quiero
comenzar con este anuncio que recién
hacía la ope se dice que estamos en el
mejor momento hablando del continente
americano en el mejor momento de la
pandemia los casos van presentando
algunas mejorías los países van
presentando mejoría a nivel económico y
también sanitario que reflexiona si
usted al respecto
bueno yo creo que no hay buenos momentos
en una pandemia
lo que se ve ahorita es una reducción de
los casos y lo que nos debe permitir es
en hacer ese ese avance que necesitamos
en las pruebas de vacunación masiva de
aprobar medicamentos para hacer
neutralización del virus y de acelerar
el proceso de vacunación en niños el
hecho de que haya reducción de casos lo
que nos debe hacer es incrementar la
preparación para reducir la propagación
y no relajarnos simplemente abriendo la
economía y no tomando las previsiones
para no tener un colapso posterior no
son buenos momentos son momentos de
preparación doctor todos los días
aprendemos algo nuevo referente a esta
pandemia referente al coronavirus y
seguimos descubriendo nuevos efectos y
nuevos síntomas provocados por el cob y
19 quiero que hablemos de el síndrome
inflamatorio
multisistémico infantil que está
atacando a los menores de edad que ya
han padecido el kobe 19 y empiezan a
presentar casos dos o seis semanas
después de haber padecido kobe 19 que
dice la comunidad científica y médica
referente a este tema
santiago desde desde que el brote en
italia nos llamó la atención que se
incrementó hasta 30 veces más la
aparición de esta enfermedad que era
parecida a una enfermedad ya los niños
que sea una enfermedad de kawasaki
y nos llamó la atención en la población
pediátrica esa situación como en estos
momentos en la pandemia se ha desplazado
hacia la población infantil porque ya la
mayoría de adultos están vacunados los
casos de kobe estamos viendo con mayor
frecuencia esta enfermedad esta
enfermedad si se diagnostica rápidamente
tiene tratamiento hemos visto ya casi
ser en toda américa latina y en colombia
especialmente y colocando medicamentos
se puede buscar la resolución pero eso
también es una alarma para que tengamos
que vacunar a los niños como prioridad
para evitar estas complicaciones que
pueden ser secuelas después de la
infección viral por eso es importante
también vacunar los ya varios países
están habilitando la vacunación para los
menores de edad doctor quiero
transmitirle una pregunta de uno de
nuestros seguidores que es una pregunta
que recibimos a través de las redes
sociales y es ahora que está disponible
la tercera dosis o vacuna de refuerzo
que vacuna debo elegir
las terceras dosis tienen algunas pautas
y en general se debe colocar la misma
vacuna que se colocó en la pauta inicial
pero se pueden estar con otras vacunas
que es lo que se llama pauta heteróloga
se puede utilizar si se usó una vacuna
en una comunidad de no virus o lo
contrario si se usó una vacuna del virus
como jansen nuestra técnica colocar una
una rn a eso ya se está haciendo en el
mundo se está estableciendo y las
vacunas son seguras y también efectivas
e incluso muy efectivas cuando se coloca
esa tercera dosis con una parte
heteróloga es decir que hay que
vacunarse y si hay la probabilidad y
lineamiento del país de hacer el
refuerzo hacerlo y hay ya unos
lineamientos muy claros de qué vacunas
se pueden utilizar pero en general
cualquiera de las vacunas pueden servir
con el refuerzo doctor para terminar
esta consulta quiero preguntarle por ese
estudio publicado esta semana que habla
de luxe o el uso de la box amina que es
un antidepresivo que es genérico es
bastante barato a nivel comercial pero
tal parece que evita tener un qubit
fuerte o un kobe prolongado ya lo hemos
analizado acá
si este medicamento tiene un efecto
antiviral que se demostró desde las
fases iniciales ya se empezaron a hacer
pruebas y se encontró que efectivamente
reduce la probabilidad de
hospitalización o de progresión de la
enfermedad sin embargo está por
establecer es en qué momento se ha
colocado qué dosis y en qué pacientes
porque también tiene efectos adversos
pero es un medicamento accesible tenemos
también buenas noticias que otros
medicamentos que se utilizan por ejemplo
para la reducción del colesterol tienen
un efecto antiviral cada vez conocemos
más tenemos un arsenal más fuerte en
este proceso del coi 19 y muy
seguramente estos medicamentos van a ser
parte de nuestra rutina como médicos
para tratar las enfermedades esta
enfermedad doctor pérez como siempre un
gusto gracias por aclarar todas estas
dudas y por haber comentado estos temas
para nuestra audiencia en france24
muchísimas gracias bueno vamos a avanzar
con otros temas que tenemos para el
programa vamos hasta río de janeiro allí
dejaron de exigir el uso de las
mascarillas al aire libre una medida que
también sería aplicada de brasilia la
capital federal a partir de la próxima
semana las autoridades además permitirán
la reapertura también de los clubes
nocturnos y de las salas de concierto
con un aforo de hasta el 50 por ciento
de su capacidad estas decisiones se dan
en un momento en que el presidente
brasileño jair bolsonaro está siendo
acusado por su manejo de la crisis
sanitaria después de una investigación
llevada a cabo por una comisión del
congreso brasileño el senador renán
calheiros criticó al mandatario a quien
calificó de asesino haciendo referencia
a los más de 600.000 fallecidos que deja
hasta el momento la pandemia en ese país
suramericano
the most subir también chiquis esto
demuestra claramente que ese asesino en
serie sigue siendo las mismas cosas
tiene el mismo impulso de muerte una
convulsión inmanejable y se vuelve cada
vez más complicado
y más números más cifras veamos cómo ha
avanzado la vacunación aquí en el
continente americano les presento a
continuación el porcentaje de la
población con esquema de vacunación
completo en algunos países de nuestro
continente comenzamos en eeuu allí el 56
66 por ciento de la población ya tiene
todo el esquema completo de vacunación
colombia cierra esta semana con un 40 65
por ciento de la población vacunada con
todas las dosis ecuador alcanzó el 56
punto 41 por ciento bolivia llega al 32
punto 38 por ciento mientras que brasil
alcanzó el 55 punto 27 por ciento de la
población de vacunada con todo el
esquema completo
y nos vamos ahora hasta la isla de
pascua a unos 3.700 kilómetros de la
costa de chile en américa del sur allí
la población indígena o rapa nui como se
le conoce es decir unos 10.000
habitantes fueron convocados para
participar en una consulta sobre la
apertura de la isla al turismo y pues
también al mundo exterior tras casi dos
años del cierre de la pandemia solamente
el 67 por ciento de los votos fue en
contra de la apertura de la isla para
conocer más detalles vamos a conversar
con pedro pablo edmunds él es el alcalde
de la isla de pascua quien nos atiende
desde agarró a la capital de este
territorio y orán al señor alcalde
saludos por estar con nosotros gracias
por estar con nosotros lo estaba
saludando en pascuense haciendo mi mejor
esfuerzo
después de esta consulta que no es
vinculante la isla va a seguir cerrada o
ustedes planean levantar algunas de las
restricciones y habrá una leve apertura
del territorio
nosotros
santiago
estamos hoy día con la isla cerrada la
isla está cerrada porque nosotros lo
solicitamos hace 18 meses atrás
para evitar que nosotros nos contagiemos
y nosotros desde un principio o sea hace
18 meses atrás tomamos la decisión como
comunidad toda de que solamente la isla
va a abrir nuevamente su aeropuerto es
el único lugar de entrada a la isla de
personas tanto de aquí para allá como de
allá para acá abriríamos solamente bajo
dos variables o primicia primero que la
isla esté al máximo de vacunación
o sea más del 80%
segundo que nuestro puerto de entrada
que es santiago de chile-
estuviese en un estado desván debido a
la baja en un mínimo de cuadro de
infestación y en un mínimo de porcentaje
de infestación
solamente esas dos condiciones
podríamos
nosotros evaluaríamos la fecha de
apertura de rapa nui
a vuelos comerciales
desde ese momento hasta ahora la isla se
ha mantenido con vuelos humanitarios que
significa un vuelo a la semana para
garantizar nuestra sustentabilidad en
alimentos en enseres necesidades
urgentes
medicinas etcétera
ahora la pregunta suya si queremos abrir
o no abrir evidente que queremos abrir
pero las condiciones para abrir están
entregadas están dadas están explicadas
lo que pasó el domingo pasado es una
consulta de la comunidad indígena que no
es la comunidad toda es la comunidad
indígena que está a cargo de administrar
25 sitios sagrados nuestro que el estado
de chile le presentó para administrar en
50 años y ellos dentro del contexto de
dar cuenta del manejo de esos sitios
hicieron una consulta a sus asociadas y
fueron sus asociados quienes llegaron a
manifestar lo que usted ya sabe
alcalde el turismo era básico para la
economía de la isla de pascua como han
hecho para mantenerse a flote evitar el
colapso económico y también evitar un
deterioro en la calidad de vida de los
habitantes
bueno desde el primer día nos
organizamos programa nos viene
trabajando un plan de sustentabilidad
desde hace más de 8 años y en
concordancia con los objetivos de
sustentabilidad que las naciones unidas
acordó para el planeta a través de la
agenda 2030 en ginebra el año 2015 desde
entonces que también rábano hoy ha
venido trabajando en un plan de
sustentabilidad
y ese plan de sustentabilidad se aplicó
completamente a partir de 18 meses atrás
para sustentar a la comunidad que quedó
sin empleo
partiendo por
los miembros de la comunidad indígena
más de nuba que quedó completamente sin
empleo porque ellos sí viven 100% del
turismo ahí quedó desempleado
de 400 personas o sea 400 familias rapa
nui quedaron sin empleo y la
municipalidad se ha hecho cargo en un
plan que se llama plan pro empleo
que tiene varias
implicancias y esas implicancias tienen
que ver también con empezar aa
inculcarnos a nosotros mismos el
concepto de auto sustentabilidad y es
así es como rapa nui se ha mantenido
hasta ahora
interesante el señor alcalde
precisamente allí en su isla el 73% de
la población ya está vacunada pero el
centro médico de hanga roa que es la
capital no dispone de unidades de
cuidado intensivo si tienen respiradores
pero no unidades de cuidado intensivo
esta coyuntura tal vez es el momento
para equipar mejor este centro
hospitalario y tal vez para disponer de
un avión ambulancia un avión
medicalizado allí en la isla para
transportar a personas que necesiten ir
hasta santiago para ser atendidas
santiago te agradezco enormemente la
pregunta
y la
sugerencia es precisamente lo que esta
autoridad está intentando tratando de
transmitir a la autoridad nacional
competente que es el ministerio de salud
estamos intentando un encuentro al menos
virtual con el ministro para
precisamente
proponerle de que a partir de esta
coyuntura muy especial que está viviendo
el mundo y especialmente nosotros el
raval hoy creemos que es el momento de
hacer esa inversión
es el tiempo de invertir en nuestro
hospital y crear finalmente lo que por
décadas la comunidad rapa nui ha estado
reclamando
gobierno tras gobierno
cuales es implementar el sistema anti
usi y acá en rapa nui de forma tan de
que tengamos un servicio de salud
completo
robustecido porque gracias a los bam de
micos descubrimos de que nuestro
hospital es muy precario y
no nos va a ayudar no va a poder
contener
ningún caso de emergencia covite
entonces somos el hospital más alejado
del planeta
no solamente de chile del planeta son
4000 kilómetros de distancia a la
siguiente opción de salud
solucionable y por lo tanto es la
oportunidad de invertir y hacer que este
servicio sea robusto no solamente para
rapa nui sino que también para quienes
pasan nuestra vecindad como los barcos
hay barcos cruceros o hay barcos de
carga hay barcos pesqueros hay todo
estos navíos que transitan en aguas
internacionales y cuando pasa de san
francisco california hacia sídney
australia por ejemplo
pasa mucho hay un transporte constante y
sufren a veces accidentes graves en los
mismos buques y lo único lugar cercano
y no ha pasado ha sucedido muchos
ejemplos y no pudimos resolver su
problema de ahí también hay una
oportunidad para chile y como país de
hacer esa inversión y este es el momento
de hacerlo y ojalá pudiéramos hacerlo
antes de apertura rapa nui al turismo
alcalde edmonds muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros aquí en france 24 siempre
muy atentos estamos de lo que sucede
allí en esta isla vale la pena decir que
se han registrado solamente ocho casos
de kobe 19 desde que comenzó la pandemia
y desde septiembre del 2020 no han
tenido ningún hospitalizado ni tampoco
personas fallecidas allí en la isla de
pascua cambiamos de tema el próximo 8 de
noviembre eeuu levantará las
restricciones impuestas a los viajeros
internacionales lo que representará un
impulso para la economía del país a
partir del turismo pero eso sí pone fin
precisamente al turismo de vacunas que
era permitido por ejemplo para los
ciudadanos latinoamericanos a partir del
8 de noviembre este país tendrá nuevas
medidas o restricción para el ingreso de
los extranjeros por ejemplo les contamos
algunas de ellas es necesario tener la
pauta completa de vacunación es decir
una o dos dosis dependiendo del caso de
la vacuna que usted tenga sólo se
permite el ingreso a las personas que
tengan vacunas que sean avaladas por la
fd y por la o ms asimismo deben tener un
certificado de test negativo de un pcr
realizado tres días antes de embarcar su
vuelo rumbo a los estados unidos quienes
no estén vacunados deberán mostrar este
mismo certificado de un test negativo de
una pcr pero realizado un día antes de
embarcar rumbo a los estados unidos
y nos vamos ahora a hacer un repaso de
la situación en perú este país allí se
registra la mayor cantidad de muertes
por millón de habitantes en el mundo y
hay algunos retrasos también en la
vacunación vamos a ir hasta lima para
conocer más detalles con francisco
zacarías para ampliar esta información
francisco cómo va gracias por estar con
nosotros como siempre en el programa y
comienzo preguntándole por las demoras
en la vacunación que hay en las
comunidades indígenas algo que fue
denunciado a lo largo de esta semana que
dicen
hola santiago la defensoría del pueblo
alertó que perú se vendría produciendo
una demora en la vacunación contra kobe
19 a los pueblos indígenas de los andes
y la amazonía el organismo reveló que al
22 de octubre sólo el 28 por ciento de
la población indígena amazónica ha
recibido a las 2 dosis previstas según
los registros que el ministerio de salud
tenía programado una meta de 393.000 287
personas inmunizadas sin embargo sólo se
vacunó a más de 123.000 con la primera
dosis y más de 85 mil con la segunda
dosis para la defensoría esto representa
un escaso avance a casi dos meses de
culminar el año la entidad estatal
exhortó al ministerio de economía y
finanzas garantizar un presupuesto que
comprende el reforzamiento a la
vacunación y la atención en los puestos
de salud localizados en las comunidades
de las regiones amazónicas y andinas del
perú se advierte que si el gobierno no
toma acciones se limitaría la capacidad
de respuesta frente a una tercera ola
del coi 19 francisco también preocupa el
aumento de los casos de contagio en los
menores de edad por qué está sucediendo
esto
la seguridad social reveló que del 3 al
9 de octubre se registraron 120 casos de
niños y la semana siguiente 170 el
organismo afirma que la cantidad
desciende a un 42 por ciento el ministro
de salud fernando ceballos reconoció que
108 menores están hospitalizados acepto
que si hubo un incremento pero señaló
que no se trata de una cifra
considerable sin embargo especialistas
del instituto nacional de salud del niño
piden a los padres de familia no
descuidar los protocolos sanitarios para
proteger a la población infantil y
recomiendan no exponer a los niños a
contagios de alcohol y 19 en las
celebraciones de halloween por su parte
el sindicato de maestros del perú afirmó
que el incremento de contagios del sars
con 12 menores presenta un escenario
complicado al retorno de las clases
semipresenciales que fueron anunciadas
para marzo del 2022 los maestros exigen
diálogo al gobierno para abordar un
mejor manejo de la crisis sanitaria y de
la problemática del magisterio francisco
hablemos de la tercera dosis cuando va a
empezar a ser inoculada en la ciudadanía
peruana
más de 100.000 trabajadores del sector
salud fueron inoculados con la dosis de
refuerzo teniendo la primera línea
atención protegida las autoridades
alistan vacunación de la tercera dosis a
los adultos mayores de 65 años que
podrían comenzar oficialmente entre el 1
y 2 de noviembre el requisito principal
es que las personas tengan más de 6
meses de haber recibido la segunda dosis
de la vacuna contra kobe y 19 para
cumplir el objetivo el ministerio de
salud articula su base de datos la cual
será contrastada con la población que
haya completado el esquema de vacunación
el sector salud afirma que tiene más de
un millón 920 mil personas aptas para
poder recibir la tercera dosis la
estrategia es aplicar la inmunización
por regiones y se contempla incluir a
pacientes con comorbilidades francisco
muchas gracias por este completo reporte
desde la ciudad de lima nos vamos ahora
hasta centroamérica nicaragua es uno de
los países que más atrás está en el tema
de la vacunación si se compara con otros
países de la región como panamá costa
rica o 'el salvador' incluso las cifras
oficiales son algo confusas y han sido
dadas a conocer a cuentagotas veamos
algunas de ellas nicaragua reporta más
de 16.000 casos confirmados de kobe 19
unas 208 mil personas o no perdón a las
208 personas han fallecido debido al
cobro y 19 y solamente algunas ongs
independientes y algunos medios
independientes han podido reportar que
el 5,41 por ciento de la población ha
recibido el esquema completo de
vacunación
y ante esta falta de vacunas ha
provocado que algunos nicaragüenses
hayan tenido que desplazarse hasta la
vecina honduras para poder recibir
alguna vacuna contra el kobe y 19 eeuu
también ya donó un lote de vacunas que
fue recibido en managua así están las
cosas veamos
montando a caballo así es como llegan a
honduras miles de nicaragüenses con la
esperanza de recibir la vacuna contra el
kobe 19 la búsqueda la hacen en dos
pasos fronterizos aduaneros empujados
por la carencia de suministros en su
país de origen empezaron el anterior
jueves por invitación del presidente
hondureño
la solidaridad y hermandad de los
hondureños traspasa las fronteras
habilitamos punto de vacunación en
frontera con nicaragua para aplicar de
250 a 500 dosis al día contra el cob y
19 a nuestros hermanos nicaragüenses
y no curan a las personas mayores de 12
años con modernas y a las embarazadas
con fai ser obviamente que estamos muy
agradecidos porque este gobierno se ha
preocupado más por nosotros nuestro
propio gobierno y han sido muy amables
entendernos paciencia porque somos un
exceso de personas increíble ya estamos
aquí todos días tenemos de estar aquí
por una vacuna imagínense lo que tenemos
que pasar nosotros no nicaragüenses por
la irresponsabilidad del gobierno de
nicaragua la vicepresidenta de nicaragua
rosario murillo aseguró que el estado
nicaragüense ya vacuno al 53 87 por
ciento de su población sin especificar
si lo han hecho con el esquema completo
sin embargo la organización our branding
data refuta al gobierno asegurando que
nicaragua ha inoculado apenas al 5% y
que usaron además de los fármacos
permitidos vacunas que carecen de la
aprobación de la oms como las cubanas
abdalá y soberana dos debido al difícil
acceso a la vacunación en el país
centroamericano también españa noruega
panamá y la india han donado dosis para
los nicaragüenses
brevemente les presentamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana en
nuestro continente brevemente les cuento
que la fd a la administración federal de
alimentos y medicamentos de eeuu emitió
la autorización del uso de emergencia de
la vacuna contra el cob y 19 para
menores de edad entre los 5 y los 11
años es la primera vacuna autorizada en
ese país para los más pequeños y este
miércoles en bogotá la capital de
colombia registró cero fallecimientos
por kobe 19 una cifra que no reportaba
desde el inicio de la pandemia de kobe
19 las autoridades bogotanas también
indicaron que van a exigir un carnet de
vacunación para la apertura total de la
ciudad a partir del primero de noviembre
y brevemente les cuento que uruguay y la
farmacéutica pfiezer valiente que
anunciaron un acuerdo por 3.7 millones
de dosis para el año 2022 las mismas
abrirán arribarán a este país
suramericano en bloques trimestrales el
gobierno pretende así dar una dosis
anual a cada uno de los ciudadanos y
también vacunar a los turistas que van a
arribar a uruguay
temporada de verano
y argentina- se une a la lista de los
países que vacunará a los turistas
menores de 18 años que ingresen a este
país argentina se prepara también para
abrir nuevamente sus fronteras a partir
del primero de noviembre
argentina se solidariza con los turistas
que llegan al país y ofrecerá la
vacunación en puntos de frontera
terrestre a partir del mes de noviembre
para los demás viajeros mayores de 18
años será un requisito el esquema
completo de vacunación y una prueba psr
negativa a 72 horas previas al ingreso a
territorio argentino atento que tenemos
stock suficiente de dosis de vacuna para
poder vacunar a todos los argentinos y
argentinas en todas las etapas de la
vida como compartimos avanzar con la
oferta a los turistas y las turistas que
vengan a argentina fundamentalmente
menores de 18 años que son quienes van a
poder ingresar sin tener la vacunación
por turismo y por supuesto a las
personas que ingresen por alguna
excepción ofrecerles la vacuna cuando
vengan a nuestro país la última vez que
argentina cerró sus fronteras fue a
fines de junio de este año ante la
llegada de la variante delta al
continente sudamericano el gobierno solo
permitía la entrada de 600 personas por
día al país la reapertura promoverá el
turismo en esta nación que es uno de los
motores de la reactivación económica
así lo manifestó el ministro de turismo
argentino el turismo va a cumplir un
papel central en la generación de
trabajo y desarrollo para nuestros
pueblos
argentinas también aplicará la tercera
dosis de la vacuna contra el kobe 19 a
personas mayores de 3 años
inmunocomprometidas que hayan recibido
cualquier vacuna y a los mayores de 50
años que hayan recibido la vacuna
scinopharm
seguimos en el sur del continente nos
vamos hasta chile en donde hay un leve
aumento de los casos de contagio que ha
sido evidente aún más a lo largo de esta
semana para las autoridades vamos a ir
hasta santiago ahí está patricia luna
nuestra corresponsal quien nos va a dar
más detalles hola patrizia un gusto
saludarla como siempre hablemos del
incremento de los de los casos que es lo
que dicen las autoridades locales
hola santiago chile vive de nuevo una
alza generalizada de los casos en los
últimos 14 días según las cifras
oficiales se incrementaron un 85% la
positividad nacional se sitúa en el 3
23% mientras que la región metropolitana
que vuelve a concentrar el mayor número
de casos se sitúa en un 4% esto ha
llevado a las autoridades a tomar
medidas como retroceder a toda la región
metropolitana a la fase 3 lo que implica
cambios sobre todo en los aforos de las
actividades que afectan especialmente a
las personas no vacunadas mientras en el
país avanza la campaña de vacunación de
los 15 2 millones de personas que
constituyen la población objetivo
respecto a los 19 millones de chilenos
92 por ciento han recibido la vacuna
también se ha realizado avances en la
población que va de los 12 a los 17 años
un 90 ha recibido una primera dosis y
casi un 70% en las dos dosis y se vacuna
también a niños de 11 a 6 años de edad
además las autoridades establecieron
nuevas medidas para viajar dentro del
país será necesario pcr y también fuera
del país todos los que lleguen al
aeropuerto tendrán que guardar una
cuarentena durante cinco días hasta que
presenten un pez re negativo
patricia gracias por este reporte desde
la ciudad de santiago y otra
problemática que está viviendo chile es
la saturación de los centros de
vacunación los ciudadanos han denunciado
largas filas largas esperas sobre todo
desde que fue avalada la tercera dosis o
dosis de refuerzo veamos
vacunatorios saturados cientos de
chilenos esperan en filas de más de tres
horas para recibir la dosis de refuerzo
contra el kobe 19 un proceso que dio
inicio el 11 de agosto tras la
aprobación del gobierno debido al
aumento de contagios en los últimos
meses y que ya fue habilitada para
menores de 55 años
[Aplausos]
a una mala noticia
el aumento de casos y la congestión en
los centros de vacunación ha obligado a
las autoridades a tomar medidas
adicionales entre ellas abrir algunos
centros de vacunación los fines de
semana para brindar mayor acceso a los
fármacos y volver obligatoria la
aplicación de la tercera dosis para
poder usar el pase de movilidad
requisito que entrará en vigor el 1º de
diciembre sin embargo más de 5.2
millones de ciudadanos ya han recibido
la dosis de refuerzo aún así los casos
siguen aumentando la dieta y como un
número importante de personas que no han
iniciado su proceso vacunación cuando
vemos las tasas de ingreso aún si un 41%
son personas que no han iniciado su
proceso de vacunación en la última
semana también hay ocho variables como
las personas han disminuido esta
percepción de riesgo por lo tanto las
reuniones sociales y estamos frente a
una variante del está que también en
cuanto contagiosa según la organización
haber word in their a más del 76 por
ciento de su población ya está
completamente inmunizada incluyendo a
niños de hasta 6 años la mayoría de
residentes chilenos han sido inoculados
con la vacuna de sinovac sin embargo
también se han aplicado los fármacos de
facer as atrás y cansino
y ahora demos un vistazo a otras
noticias relacionadas con el hobby 19
destacadas en redes comenzamos en esta
publicación de france24 punto como reino
unido- retira a siete países de américa
latina- de su lista roja de viajes
siendo estos países colombia perú panamá
república dominicana haití venezuela y
ecuador- la medida entra en vigor a
partir del primero de noviembre
y para el cierre del programa los
dejamos con estas imágenes de un altar
elaborado en la ciudad de mexico para
recordar a las víctimas que ha dejado el
cob y 19 esto coincide con los
preparativos de la celebración del día
de los muertos que es una de las más
emblemáticas tradiciones mexicanas con
esto nos despedimos sigan con la
programación de france 24 amianto nativo
[Música]